for those of you to know alex trebek
host of jeopardy
passed away yesterday after being
diagnosed with stage four pancreatic
cancer
alex was one of the most iconic game
show hosts of all time i believe
he didn't even plan to go into
broadcasting he was on our show in 2015
and he told me he had no ambitions of
being a game show host when he was a kid
robin
when i was a kid unlike you i didn't
want to grow up to be
a quiz or game show host you want to be
an actor no
you did not i had three ambitions and i
told an audience about this the other
night
i wanted to be a pilot a doctor or prime
minister of canada
well you really missed the mark i know
and i tell him i said
you know you guys are honoring a failure
i didn't make any of my ambition
the original host of uh jeopardy was art
fleming he was the host until 1979 when
jeopardy was revived in 1984.
alex produced and hosted the show here's
a clip
the first contract i signed for uh
jeopardy
they have you by the balls right well
they called me because i had replaced
chuck woolery
on wheel of fortune for one week when he
was ill
and they said we're bringing jeopardy
back
into syndication and we'd like you to
host it i said are you going to pay me
i said yep i said good i said how much
oh uh
and it was about half of what i was
making on the previous show
and i said who's going to produce we
don't have one yet can i produce
yeah will you pay me to produce yeah
okay so if you combine both my salaries
for the first three years
then i almost made as much as i had been
making before on another
program alex always took himself very
seriously on jeopardy which i think was
part of the success of the show
yeah but he had a great sense of humor
too when he was on our show
he talked about the time he accidentally
got high on hash brownies
i went to a party at this home in malibu
and i didn't know the people uh who were
hosting the party
and they had hash brownies i love
chocolate and i
ate about four or five hash brownies the
party was on a friday
night yeah i didn't leave their home
till monday morning
is that really true no exaggeration no
exaggeration
they put me to bed friday night because
i was
almost comatose and i did not wake up
saturday
i started to wake up sunday and then i
went home
that's a bad experience alex publicly
announced that he was diagnosed with
stage four pancreatic cancer last year
and somehow he was upbeat about it which
is crazy
hi everyone i have some news to share
with all of you
and it's in keeping with my longtime
policy of being open
and transparent with our jeopardy fan
base
this week i was diagnosed with stage
four pancreatic
cancer now normally the prognosis for
this
is not very encouraging but i'm gonna
fight this
and i'm gonna keep working and with the
love and support of my family and
friends
and with the help of your prayers also
i plan to beat the low survival rate
statistics for this disease
truth told i have to because under the
terms of my contract
i have to host jeopardy for three more
years
so help me keep the faith there you go
and we'll win
we'll get it done thank you what a man
you know i admired that so much because
i am so the opposite you people would
suffer if i had pancreatic cancer here's
another fact i asked him how he keeps
healthy his response was
rather surprising because i always
thought this guy was a health nut listen
to this response
how do you stay in such good shape i
drink that's it and that
but do you exercise you you're well you
are i don't exercise you don't do any of
that no
just watch what you wow no i have good
dinners
and i joke about the fact that i used to
have the breakfast of champions which
was a diet coke
and the snickers but then a nutritionist
got hold of me and he says well
alex you can't do that it's good it's
going to harm your health you've got to
change so i changed to a diet pepsi
and a milky way oh dear are you
serious yeah no he's not i am are you
really that's my breakfast are you
kidding me i kid you not why do i think
you're kidding
i don't know you're in really good shape
well yeah
even as he faced his death alex was
still so level-headed here's an
interview he gave last october to a
canadian television station
the thought of the pancreatic cancer
does not frighten me you're not afraid
of dying
no no not afraid of dying
as i told somebody the other day one
thing they're not going to
say at my funeral as a part of a eulogy
he was taken from us too soon
i'm 79 years old so hey i've lived a
good life a full life
alex trebek was a class act